I just want to say I am thrilled to be your new captain.
I want this to be an efficient ship
But also one that you're glad to be serving on.
Lieutenant commander Bordas, your entire species is male isn't it?
That is correct sir
Probably not a lot of arguments about
leaving the toilet seat up and that kind of thing or..
Bucklands urinate only once per year
Really? That's, I mean, I'm up two, three times a night.
That is unfortunate.
It is.
The Orville Premieres Sunday September 10th on Fox
Ed, have a seat. I have good news,
There's a ship available, the USS Orville.
Ever since I was a kid I have wanted to serve on an exploratory vessel
You're nobody's first choice for this job, but we have 3,000 ships to stand and we need captains
Can I have one of these Mints?
Those are marbles.
We're giving you one last chance.
I just want to say I am thrilled to be your new captain.
I want this to be an efficient ship
But also one that you're glad to be serving on
Lieutenant Commander Boardis, your entire species is male isn't it?
That is correct sir.
Probably not a lot of arguments about leaving the toilet seat up and that kind of thing right?
Bucklands urinate only once per year.
Really that's I mean, I'm up to three times a night.
That is unfortunate.
It is.
Time to meet the locals.
Hi. I'm captain Ed Mercer.
Holy crap!
We don't mean your family any harm
Well we did just shoot his dad.
Aside from shooting your dad, we don't mean your family any harm
Captain there's a message coming in from Admiral Halsey
It says that an executive officer has become available.
No, no no no no no no no no no
Oh, crap,
Sorry, man, you okay? Yeah, it's all good. Man.
You okay?
Yeah, all good, sorry
All right, no worries.
The Captain does not appear to be pleased at the arrival of his first officer.
They were married.
No way.
You know how many times I tried to talk to you.
I was the one who suggested couples th-
The therapist was your brother-in-law
This should be really fun trip for all of us.
Perhaps we should not be talking about this.
Oh no no no, we're talking about this. This is a thing
You'll be delivering supplies to the science station on Epsilon 2
Thank you for coming
We need protection.
Protection from what?
The Krill.
We have figured out a way to manipulate the speed of events
So it's an anti Banana ray.
It's really interesting.
We need no longer fear the banana.
Does it work on all fruit?
What about salads?
You do realize this could be used as a weapon.
That's why you're here
Orders for Captain Mercer, just detected a krill destroyer entering orbit.
Door's jammed.
Alara, you want to open this jar of pickles for me?
I loosened it for you
Return fire.
Give me the device, or i will destroy your ship.
Sorry, can you, can move like two steps to your right?
It's just a lot of dead space there, just
perfect, yeah sorry, you were just very weirdly framed.
What?
What is that, is that a beer?
Yeah I'm nervous, you know it's a new ship want to make a good impression.
It's 9:15 in the morning
Sorry